well home oh wow
oh oh wow so beautiful that's more like
it
whoa what the hell oh my god you're so
cute look up yet
yeah yes okay whoa Oh No Oh No
how do I change how do I get out of this
outfit hey can I pet you excuse me kitty
hey kitty you name it touchy
oh you like that kitty hey son don't
change can I look at your butt please
stay there let me look at you let me I
just want to look at you
alright and I stay there turn around
turn around turn around come on that's
right let me lick shake that ass shake
that ass for me oh hell yeah
Dornan you want to be my boyfriend what
are you gay or something come on you
thank you
maybe one day
Hey anyone oh you want to join me okay
I'm gonna join me that's what I'm
talking about
hey it's mark blood but I'm the real
motherboard does anyone want to touch me
no fine you know what
that's fair can you do leave no I can't
cuz I'm mark but can you uh [ __ ] can you
do this oh my god stop that song Jesus
Christ you are the worst human nope
don't listen to him you are the worst
human I'm like a generic white guy of
course I'm the worst human that's true
that's probably true alright now
apologize to Shawn
sorry sure yeah that's right now test
him go ahead and kiss kiss and make up
come on Shawn don't be shy he's too sure
no that's fine respect just bend over
Shawn you gotta jump you gotta jump for
this to happen Shawn yes yes come on yes
yes yes whoa look at those moves got my
shot
come on jump you just gotta jump like
this all right come on all right how
about this I kiss you instead huh about
that come on I kissed it for sure I
kissed for sure yes yes yes I think I'm
still to show you so good it's so good
wait wait wait wait if I stand up here
and then I go this way and then you can
kiss my ass
how about that huh you make fun of Shawn
you pay the consequences
what happened I think I'm lost
connection
great oh come on what is happening oh my
god
Ron I mean Harry Potter land oh yeah oh
my god it's Harry Potter that's me oh my
god you look fabulous thank you
high-five give me give me song keep
doing what you're doing dude listen up
listen up not to click you know when you
know you're listening to shut the [ __ ]
up
yeah you know when you have a fear
that's cool think you can grab a sword
ride a gun locked right okay oh my god
what do you want like see this is the
most [ __ ] worthless skin ever
it's a Harry Potter without a [ __ ]
magic wand look it's empty I don't have
anything I'm a piece of [ __ ] no magic
huh it's very realistic
oh my god it's sands sands
and where's the Paris come on dividend
come on give me a hug come on
[Music]
suck-up yeah what do you do and I will
never love me dream I'm gonna kiss you
can kiss my ass
how about that oh you come here can I
ride you come on come on come on let me
get inside hey hey since it you just ran
me over
oh hell yeah
hey get out this is my car - ah though I
have been in this space before I on the
street and I know it's my place to go
calling you
to me you know that song he left
hey little Pippen
give me the anime gold right now or
you're gonna get it hey hey listen here
listen here I don't care how tiny and
cute you are give me them gold can you
believe this
don't point at me I don't point at me
okay I've got a gun wait you have so
many friends oh my god can I be your
friend please I am like so much I am an
anime girl in real life I have really
nice luscious anime tits in real life
but in game I'm John wick hey my seat
get up there excuse me you want to be
friends
get off the sea goodbye
hello hello she is she's if hello now
she's here he is herobrine hello the
legs are moving the legs are moving Hey
jump jump or I'll shoot
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it she
didn't do it
I'm I am gonna do it unless did you
[Music]
hey you're not leaving hey listen I'm
doing you a favor okay
[Music]
jump and no one gets hurt we're gonna
Hokage but she knows I know shut up I
jump down on purpose you want to see the
dad go in go in yet no but no buts
because I says I'm the one with the
gutter yes no nanny
Hey go I'm not afraid of shoot I love
you
no that's fine oh she loves you okay all
right okay all right you're both going
in the home go in the hole we're best
friends snap oh what a nice dog oh good
guy stay away from the dog what's what's
the matter there's nothing but there's
nothing wrong in my phone it's called a
Potter summer right it's not a condition
it's actually work
there's nothing your fingers that might
might mute them do that
oh these do you rake leaves in your lawn
it's no listen you have never seen
fingers clearly look I have seen fingers
you never seem to make sure because this
is how fingers like the model finger
[Music]
it's not a condition this is normal and
people like my fingers I have you know a
lot of people compliment me on my
fingers pick up the women since you have
such beautiful hands okay yeah I can
look at this oh look there's a there's a
webbing right here excuse me my lady
would you like to hold hands oh [ __ ]
we're Slavs parties excuse me ladies
excuse me ladies
no yes what is she saying no I don't
understand why did she go
I sniff me madam mother girl here you
don't ask you just trying to show you
I'm trying to help you up alright
because I have fingers and you don't
I was trying to I know how to pick up
there's nothing wrong with he stop
listen don't look at this look at that
[Music]
[Laughter]